[Music]
good afternoon this time this session is
how to industrialize your data platform
with Google cloud platform and open
source technology
I'm Jason Clark I've been with Monsanto
/ Baer for a little over nine years now
so to start with who here has seen an
ear of corn up close and personal if you
have you've probably noticed that on
that individual ear of corn there are a
lot of individual kernels right on an
ear of corn you can have anywhere
between 800 and 1,200 kernels on that
single ear each of those kernels has a
lot of information packed inside a lot
of information that's very useful to us
within Bayer CropScience in making
decisions on how we drive our product
pipeline and what I want to talk to you
today is essentially asking the question
like what if we could take all that data
that's packed inside each of those
kernels each of those kernels that are
on those ears that are in these fields
where there's thousands of corn plants
what if we could take each data about
each of those kernels an engineer an
information pipeline that can help us
mass produce knowledge about our product
pipeline and ultimately make more
informed decisions that help drive
products useful products to market that
can aid in producing more bountiful
harvests what I want to convince you of
is that we have as an engineering team
produced an information pipeline that
leverages historic observations crop
data that we have to further
characterize our products and ultimately
improve decision making but I had a
fraction of the costs that we would
incur to have done it previously so
let's take a take a step back here
I'm with Bayer AG I'm actually more a
part of I'm a bigger part of Bayer
CropScience and when we look at our
product pipeline for
Bayer CropScience it really comes down
to three high-level steps number one
we're gonna try to enter identify market
needs right what
treatments can we pair with seeds and
genetic characteristics that we know
about our corn plants as an example how
can we pair these things together and
produce a product that ultimately
improves yield for our farmer customers
once we've identified what that market
what those market needs are you know
we'll start to actually develop those
product concepts step 2 when we're
developing those what we're altima doing
is over the course of years taking each
one of those seeds planting them
pollinating them harvesting them and
starting that whole cycle over shipping
seed around the globe and performing
that cycle year over year and while
we're planting and harvesting these
things in between there we're measuring
a lot of data into recording a lot of
data about those seeds fundamentally
there are two data sets that our team
cares about that are that are that
contribute to driving that product
pipeline genetics data genetic data
which would include genomics and
phenotypic data so genetic data being
you know what do we know about the
genetic makeup the genome of these seeds
that were removing through a product
pipeline and phenotypic data being what
can we actually observe is this year of
corn yellow or is it white right that's
a very simple characteristic but you can
imagine much more complex
characteristics that were we're
measuring as well and then ultimately
once we've we've identified that product
concept we've developed this product
concept we're sure it's it's a the right
fit for our customers we'll
commercialize it at each of these steps
along the way there are different
elements of our data stack that are
important and what I want to do today is
tell you who we are as an engineering
team and then tell you how we've applied
some some some principles to
industrialize our platform and allow for
large scale
across our consumers and within our
platform to ultimately produce knowledge
so who are we how do I fit into this
picture I work for a really strong
engineering team called product 360
within our data landscape what we do is
we engineer a versatile enterprise wide
data asset platform that's really core
to other business layers what does that
mean well
well fundamentally what we do is we
provide access to core product data sets
in various ways various modes of access
to across various personas so everything
from other software products that are
being built within the company to data
scientists that are trying to identify
what those next product concepts could
be all the way up to our domain experts
the people working in the labs the
people that are really doing the
hands-on work to measure and observe
characteristics about these seeds that
are moving through our pipeline now what
that means is that with that variety of
consumers and spanning that long of a
pipeline again the course of years we
really build up some demand in terms of
usage of our of the platform that we
built it's kind of give you a sense for
that usage API requests so again
fundamental active mode of access for
the datasets that our team delivers is
through api's and we'll get into kind of
the different modes of access for those
api's in just a few moments but what you
can see here is on average monthly over
the course of the last year we've we've
had 323 million API requests so we're
not talking an internet scale but we're
talking pretty sizable usage for
consider when you consider that all
these consumers are within our company
now another thing that you can see here
is peak usage and what you can see is
that agriculture is fundamentally a
seasonal business right we'll see spikes
in usage at various times throughout the
year we've seen one month where we have
we've had at have
had 1.16 billion API requests across our
platform so who are those coming from
well we measure that as well and we'll
talk a little bit of later on about how
we measure this data active applications
so application being considered you know
a software product that's using our
platform in some way an analytical model
that's using our platform in some way
also inclusive of individual data
scientists that may be using our
platform in some way we've seen an
average of 85 into active applications
per month spiking up to again 116 with
with those seasonal workloads now our
platform is not stagnant it's not stale
it's changing every day we release on
average 23 times a month to production
with you know a peek in there of
releasing more than one time a day now
we're not releasing hundreds of times a
day we don't we don't have that that
need but what it does show is that our
platform is still evolving and some of
the principles that I'm going to talk to
you about help help us give give us that
wiggle room to continue to evolve the
platform as we continue to expand our
usage for n provide value for our
consumers produce new knowledge for the
organization it's kind of give you a
sense of the breadth of the platform
we're looking at about 40 a little over
40 resource collections all those
datasets those resources are all
different shapes and sizes so maybe
graph structured data so maybe
traditional relational data they're all
they're all different but they all fit
into the puzzle in some way and we don't
just distribute our databases we
distribute our engineering team as well
where we've got a team of 30 plus data
engineers you know split into five to
seven person teams focused on different
vertical areas within product 360 so
what demand like that how do we go about
building a platform that we can scale
that we can use that our consumers can
use and our consumers can scale
to do that we've had to develop some
some basic principles and if we think
about this like we're designing we're
designing a factory of knowledge here
and we're trying to layout our factory
floor what are some of the principles of
in designing that factory floor that
we've we've tried to to follow well step
one number one is we want a minute
minimize retooling right we don't want
to have to reconfigure that factory
floor and incur downtime in that
production of knowledge if we don't have
to we want to minimize that number two
is we want standardization and we want
each component in that on that factory
floor we want us job and its purpose in
life to be obvious right we want it we
want somebody to be able to look at that
layout and say I know why this fitness
piece is here but we also want you know
that indirection as an engineering team
to be able to swap a new component in
that it does that job a little bit at
least a little bit better if necessary
right so we want that ability to
refactor but we don't want to cause our
consumers to have to retool the the next
thing is we you know if our factory
floor stops working we're no good for
our consumers we're not producing
knowledge we need a really clear view of
the health of our factory floor right we
need key performance indicators that can
tell us how that factory floor is
operating and where the bottlenecks are
at right where where are we introducing
bottlenecks into this process of
producing knowledge so I want to walk
you through in the next few slides how
we apply some of these principles and
how we design for them and then what I
want to do is come back and make it more
real so we'll talk kind of about the you
know in an abstract way about those
principles over the next few slides and
then we'll bring it back and we'll talk
to a real use case and show you how
we've applied those principles in a real
information pipeline so let's start with
standardization right we want we want
those components to easily be swapped in
and out but we want their purpose to be
obvious
that comes back to to me to readability
and flexibility those two things so
let's start with readability if we think
about readability from a code
perspective what does that mean it means
my fundamentally my code base is Moorman
maintainable because someone else can
come in and understand what that
software is is intending to do we want
our data model to operate the same way
we want our consumers to be able to come
in look at one resource you get
commitment familiar and comfortable with
that resource and then when they go to
use another resource not have to worry
about reconfiguring their mental model
we want it to look similar we want our
resources to look similar such that they
can jump across those resources with a
minimum amount of friction and really
combine data together to produce new
information for the company
standardization is how we get there and
the way we've standardized is by
adopting Google's resource oriented
design guidelines if you've ever used
the Google Cloud api's this will feel
familiar to you this is a lot of the
principles that are applied in the
Google Cloud api's and you'll see some
things show up here in a few moments
directly out of that those design
guidelines one thing that really
cemented for me kind of you know putting
importance in API design was Martin
Ali's talk last year at cloud next
called designing quality api's it's a
really good watch if you're interested
in API design and why it's important and
and how to go about it it's a really
good watch and a really good place to
start
now talked about readability standard is
standardization is helping us helping
give us that readability and it's
helping give us that that ability to
swap in new components as an engineering
team but what about flexibility if we're
so rigid that we have to change our our
API is every time a new attributes
introduced into a business workflow that
maybe it's something's hyper specific to
that workflow that's going to be
retooling for us it's going to be
potentially retooling for our consumers
by way of a breaking change to our API
or a new version of the API that they
have to wrap
adopt right it's going to cause churn
it's gonna potentially cause downtime
and loss of productivity so what we've
done is we've adopted a concept from the
resource oriented design guidelines and
we tried it with these guidelines we try
to not be dogmatic we try to be
pragmatic so we'll start with the
resource oriented design guidelines use
that as our base and then if there's
something that maybe makes more sense
because we have more context about our
development workflow or our customers
workflows we'll adapt it and we'll make
it fit that but we always we use the
resource oriented design guidelines as
our base resource oriented resource
annotations are an example of that
there's a concept and resource for me to
design called labels and if you've used
the Google cloud a P is again you've
seen this concept or really any cloud
api you've seen this concept in some way
it's essentially bring your own context
right I don't have to tell Google cloud
hey can you add this attribute to the
compute engine API so that I can capture
it I can add that and it's specific to
me and it's it's relevant to me it's
understandable to me we've adopted that
same principle with our API design we've
got we've got a lot of workflows
internally that spin up and spin down
quickly right we want to be that base we
don't want to have to change our API Xin
introduced down time with every change
to the business workflow so this enables
that bring your own context an example
here is that this is really just key
value pair data right so we've got some
base schema that is giving you a
definition of the kind of core
Enterprise attributes for that
particular resource and then you've got
annotations that you can apply on top of
that resource to bring your own context
an example would be you know if I wanted
to label a particular seed as being part
of a drought initiative I could add that
annotation by way of a key value pair
and in some cases we do have controlled
vocabulary implemented over some of
those annotations but mostly it's
freeform it's meant to be um you know a
piece of flexibility for our consumers
another way that we enable flexibility
is through
this concept of resource sets so we've
got resource collections that we expose
as api's and then you know I think what
we've seen a lot of is that people like
their things and they like their groups
of things they want to they want to
bring context by way of taxonomically
organizing that data in some way that's
been meaningful and relevant to them
resource sets give us that it's another
resource it's structured as a resource
standard API but it gives you the
ability to group a particular resource
by way of filter values right so let's
say I wanted to have a keep a list of
all the products that are moving through
the pipeline for 2019 well if I have a
products resource and a product sets
resource I can do that I can provide the
filter parameters and I can either
manually update that thing or we're
moving more towards this concept of
dynamic sets which is basically filter
parameters with context right so give it
a name name that thing and then it can
be reused across the organization so
it's a way to deduplicate that data but
also give our consumers some some
control and some flexibility in the
management of that data the other side
here is that we don't want to impose
trade-offs on our consumers where we
don't have to we want to push that the
ability to make trade-offs back into
their control there are a couple ways
that we do that so we've talked I've
talked in generality about resource
api's right resource just being a
particular data set we provide multiple
modes of access to each of those data
sets one is g RPC so we've we've
wholesale adopted g RPC across our
platform as a mode of access for each
data set we've also enabled rest we see
definitely more usage on the rest side
from less technical consumers people
like data scientists people that are
just there aren't programmers we're
trying to get their job done and need to
interact with these api is to access
these datasets
rust is you know going to work with more
out-of-the-box tooling and just be an
easier experience but g RPC is going to
give you that performance we've done
some head-to-head ahead benchmarks of
versus GRP see and and there's
definitely noticeable performance gain
there with t RPC but as a consumer as a
data scientist I don't want to have a
high barrier to entry for accessing
these things so we provide both of these
modes of access the kicker here is that
if I want to string together multiple
resources to really make make something
meaningful that can be more difficult
right I have to be somewhat of a
programmer to be able to do that to call
these api's do some sort of
transformation pipe that into another
API do transformation off of that how do
we make it easy for consumers to join
this data together
that's where graph QL comes in for us so
we've got a graph QL server that again
can be used by any of our consumer
prints personas bench scientists data
scientists enterprise application they
can use this graph QL server which in
turn calls our G RPC API right so we get
the performance of calling G RPC api's
but we can do a prescriptive join of
that data for the consumers this gives
again the consumer the ability to trade
off who's doing the join right if they
have more knowledge potentially about a
better way to pre-filter data and join
that with another data set they can do
that they can do that by way of G RPC or
rest they have that that that ability if
they don't want to join that data
together manually they don't have to
they can call graph QL our graph QL API
and we'll do that joint for them
both of those are synchronous modes of
access to write request response for our
consumers the third pattern here that we
follow is we've adopted cloud native
computing foundations cloud events back
to publish an event stream for each of
our resources that event stream notifies
on you know standard create update
delete operations right it tells it and
give our consumers a hook into our our
ecosystem to react async '''l
asynchronously to events you know
goings-on in our ecosystem this kind of
this again gives our consumers a way to
decide what model fits fits their
particular workflow
whether that's an enterprise application
that wants to react us as new enterprise
data elements are created or a data
scientist that is really just trying to
get these datasets combined together and
move on with their lives so they can do
really you know focus on their job their
core responsibilities that's heavily
focused on the consumer side right as an
engineering team we also try to take
that that idea of standardization and
use that as our in direction on the to
the back end and that gives us the
ability to use data structure as a
competitive advantage so again I
mentioned that you know we've got
40-plus resource collections they're all
different shapes and sizes
we've got datasets like our pedigree
ancestry data set that tracks seed
lineage right if we think about that
corn kernel we plant that we pollinate
it in some way we harvest new seed and
those seeds are linked together
genetically right one came from the
other and we do that over the course of
years but sometimes multiple times a
year for that particular line of seed
that produces a lot of data and that
data is naturally structured as a graph
and that with that data set what you see
on the right hand side here up the slide
is an image that my colleague Tim
Williamson tweeted a while back that is
actually a representation of our
ancestry data set for corn each of those
stars in this galaxy are corn seeds and
the links between them our genetic
relationships these seeds came from
these seeds right it gives you a sense
of the scale of that data set this is
just corn now we you know we we work in
a lot more crops than just corn if this
is interesting to you I would highly
encourage that you go out and look at
and watch Tim's presentation from graph
connect a couple years ago he goes more
in depth and how we've modeled data in
neo4j
for that pedigree data but the point
here is that we can specialize from an
engineering perspective right we have
that indirection none of this is novel
but that standardization gives us a good
way to kind of plug and play
we can start with a relational database
for a dataset like this if we wanted to
and then optimize the backend later and
with minimal friction or ideally no
friction for our consumers the other
side of our data footprint is cloud
spanner has rapidly become our primary
database so we're coming from a legacy
environment with a large Oracle instance
that was really good at his job for what
we needed at the time as we've moved to
a more more of a micro service model
something like cloudspinners actually
become very very useful for us we've
made smaller thinner more well-defined
resources so we're not trying to
facilitate 7 table joins to get data
back cloudspinners been a really good
fit as well because again different data
sets of different shapes and sizes size
being the key word in that we have a few
data sets that are very very large and
those are the data sets that will
actually talk through in our real life
example to give you a sense of the scale
of our spanner footprint right now we're
at about 17 terabytes across our two
environments you know about 10 10
terabytes in our production environment
and the other seven in our non
production environment and our instance
size floats between 10 and 50 nodes now
that can get expensive but we'll talk a
little bit later about how we try to
control that cost without sacrificing
performance with spanner specifically so
we've talked a lot about getting data
out of our platform let's talk about how
we get data into our platform our most
basic pattern for getting data into our
platform is essentially data generator
calling a resource API by way of G RPC
arrests right again nothing novel but
there are some some things some
characteristics about that particular
workflow that are important one it
pushes resource validation closer to the
data generator so if the data generator
gives us bad data that is synchronous we
can immediately reject that data and
give give that data generator context as
to why that data is invalid it keeps
muck out of our enterprise systems right
and it also prevents us as an
engineering team from having to get in
the muck if if that bad data is
generated the other characteristic is
that the consistency model follows that
of the resource API
so again cloths manners are as
essentially our primary database at this
point with the global consistency model
we can provide that same capability to
our consumers the flipside of that the
trade-off here is that the data
generator is sensitive to the
performance of the the resource API our
resource API is slow and we you know we
don't have alarm bells sounding from our
KPIs that data generator is going to
slow down or they're gonna have to deal
with that in some way they don't have to
engineer complexity into their system to
accommodate that
so in cases where either it's not
feasible for us to make something hyper
performant or cases where you know that
that right is just high enough latency
that it impacts the data generator and
slows their work down this this pattern
may not fit there's another pattern
where you know that that pattern works
well with kind of this new world that
we're building where we're building new
workflows out in the cloud and
engineering systems to bring us into a
new landscape the other another right
pattern that we have though is we do
have again large legacy systems that
have collected data over the course of
20 to 30 years that data is still
important we still use that data to make
a lot of decisions in our business
because we want to look at that data
over time the way we get our legacy data
into our systems in most cases is
through a product that we have
internally called the enterprise data
hub what the enterprise data hub is is a
set of replicated kafka clusters that is
managed by a central engineering team
within our company that product takes
care of bi-directional replication
between our different cloud environments
right so we have a coffee cluster on
Prem
we have a conflict cluster in AWS we
have a conflict closer in GCP and data
hub takes care of moving that data in
and out of those environments for us on
the front end of that we have change
data capture mechanisms by you know
informatica data replicator in the case
of s AP and
Oracle GoldenGate in the case of our
Oracle environment those are pushing
change capture records out that those
change capture records are making their
way to Golan Kafka consumers that we
have running out in Google Cloud and
pushing again still pushing things in
through our resource API so we're
dogfooding those those resource api is
even in this context we're not ever
making direct writes around the API to
our databases which again one hardens
our workflows right if we're dogfooding
it we're gonna harden that workflow much
quicker than waiting for our consumers
to find issues and to it's you know it's
it's given us some of the same benefit
we can leverage those flexibility
concepts as well and adapt our workflows
very much quicker one thing I would I
would stress here too is that if you're
interested in learning more about how
our data hub environment is set up
former colleague Bob Lehmann speaks to
that approach from an Kafka summit last
year this is a really another really
good watch that goes more in-depth into
our data hub set up so that particular
change pattern is generally lightweight
events right the change capture records
are you know maybe 10 15 columns not not
big and a lot of those can be kind of
treated in isolation however we have a
set of workflows particularly
particularly in the genomics world where
we've got a lot of data that is that
comes from a single event so we have a
single change capture record that comes
across that that single change record
can lead to creation of thousands of
resources all of which are fairly
heavyweight there you know there's some
meat to each of those each of those
individual resources to accommodate that
workflow you know Kafka really doesn't
encourage you to put large super large
messages on on a topic in a partition so
to accommodate that workflow we still
stream out that lightweight event we
transform that light away event by
joining it back to the legacy system and
exchanging that lightweight event for
those you know a number of large
resources we take each of those
resources and we sync them as objects in
Google Cloud storage when we do that we
rely on bucket notifications to polish
out the other side right that's our
change capture mechanism on the other
side of cloud storage so that bucket
notification fires we do in some cases a
little more manipulation of massaging to
that data and then again write it in
through the resource API so similar
approach but we're accommodating that
large transformation that has to happen
in the middle there and we're doing that
with GCSE and pub/sub the one of the
things that we get out of this this
particular workflow is that with our
Kafka workflows we can't arbitrarily
scale our consumption right scaling of a
cough consumer is bound by the number of
partitions that you have Andry
partitioning is generally not a pleasant
exercise pub/sub gives us the ability to
arbitrarily scale here we have a single
event that is infrequent that comes
across and we exchange that for a larger
amount of information and then we want
to parallel eyes really wide to consume
that information into our resource API
is as rapidly as possible pub/sub gives
us that ability we can scale out much
much wider with a button push
essentially with a change in a
kubernetes deployment size replica count
so that's one of the benefits that we
get get out of this particular work
workflow as well we don't always have
control of our legacy system and by
control I mean the ability to go back
and exchange information with it
directly an example of that for us is si
P so we don't ever touch our SI P
environment by querying it but we do
have change data capture that's
generated out of our si P system to
accommodate that we've actually paired
kafka than those change capture records
with spanner and data flow so this is
kind of more of the traditional
replicate data as is we replicate as is
in the spanner
so you'll see tables that look like si P
tables and
cloud spanner and then we use cloud
dataflow to kind of give us this concept
of a materialized view right we've got
cloud dataflow running periodically as a
scheduled job taking data out of cloud
spanner making it into the format that
we want to make it into to make it a you
know a more descriptive resource for our
consumers storing that data back in
cloud spanner and then our resource
api's are built on top of that so it's
essentially a cache right one of the
things that we get out of using cloud
dataflow here we're cloud using it
heavily using cloud dataflow Java but
one of things we get out of that is
testable business logic right we can
test those try those data
transformations that we're doing where
as if we're building you know
traditionally building a thousand line
sequel statement to build a materialized
view you get testing that is really hard
and error-prone and and all these other
things that make it really difficult to
ensure we're not introducing breaking
changes with dataflow and what Java
obviously we can unit test in a similar
way that we would any of our other
software another aspect of dataflow that
comes important here is that we can
scale that as our dataset size scales we
can increase our worker count again it's
a button push so that gives us the
ability to ingest a lot more data if
need be without a lot of operational
overhead or having to retool our
environment the trade-off here with this
workflow is that this is not near
real-time these other workflows that
we've looked at or near real-time you
know moments after that date is written
to the legacy system it'll be available
in our resource api's for consumption by
our consumers this is not this is
scheduled so this is you know every few
hours we run these transformations we
can squeeze that down and make it you
know a shorter frequency we haven't had
the need to do that but it does suffer
from this this particular aspect what
you see on the right is an example of
one of our simple dataflow jobs so when
I talk about testability this is kind of
showing you you know this is a
job testing is testing these things is
important so we talked a little bit
earlier about how it's important for us
to have key performance indicators a
view of our factory floor right we don't
want to we don't want to ever stop that
production of knowledge we want that to
be available 24/7 so now I want to talk
a little bit about some of the
reliability engineering aspects that
we've introduced into our stack the most
basic but also one of the most useful
has been instrumenting our api's with to
capture access log data API request data
this captures the essentially the who
the what the when and how long for each
of the API requests that come into our
platform this gives us a sense of how
that those those requests are those
api's are operating for our consumers
right if it's something slow we surfaced
this data through bigquery written
through pub/sub so each API hands off
the request to pub/sub we've got some
process that syncs that in a bigquery
and then we surface it for our
engineering teams using data studio so
kind of gives you that end-to-end
experience and gives our engineering
team a view of that factory floor but of
their specific segments of that factory
floor
another aspect you've seen how many of
our ingress data ingress patterns rely
on kafka what we've done is create
essentially a monitor for Kafka that's
not novel right but what we did in this
case is use kubernetes see our DS custom
resource definitions to allow our
engineering team to define their
monitoring monitoring requirements for
their Kafka consumers at deployment time
so instead of having to deploy my Kafka
consumer and then go somewhere else to
say here's how I should be alerted for
this thing you can push that information
close to the deployment this is a place
where to me kubernetes really really
shines this extensibility allows us to
describe our deployment workflow in the
terms that we use and make it
discoverable for our engineers all
through the surf
that they're interacting with to do
their application development daily that
alerts to slack you know push the
message as close to where the engineers
are but it's a set of really simple go
processes that are watching for that
that custom resource definition to
change then last but not least we've
talked a lot about spanner and I
mentioned that you know if we're running
as large spanner instance that can get
expensive we also don't want to run a
small into the spanner instance and have
that seasonal workload spike on us all
of a sudden and our API performance goes
down the drain right we want stability
but we also want cost control so we've
written a simple autoscaler component
for quad spanner that runs in kubernetes
uses a stack driver API to watch for CPU
utilization numbers right and watches
that time series and scales cloud
spanner up and down using the spanner
API as needed we've seen this
drastically reduce our spanner bill
because we were over allocating before
to guard against poor performance if we
saturated the the instance but we've
seen now that CPU utilization with this
autoscaler component hovered between 30
and 50 percent usage utilization so you
know we want to be using as much of that
capacity as we can we can't put those
those cpu cycles in the bank and save
them for later we're we're getting what
we pay for at that point in time this
has been a big addition in terms of
operations again hands off for the our
engineering team it can this autoscaler
can take action there's a little bit of
risk in that the stack driver API is a
minute behind so if we see a real sudden
burst in you know we may see a few
failed requests but overall over time
it's it helps keep our SSL lows in check
so let's make this real
let's talk a little bit about one of the
concepts that we've implemented on our
platform this information pipeline that
we've implemented on our platform over
the course of the last year what we're
doing is we're doing a process called
genotype inference so think about that
corn seed again that kernel again that
is each kernel is dense and information
what we want is we want a picture in a
window into the the information inside
that kernel genetic markers give us that
information about that the genome of
that particular corn seed right so
genome being all the different
nucleotide bases that compose that that
kernel genetically genetic marker giving
some measurement at particular locations
on the genome and those locations are
picked very strategically right we were
looking for things that ultimately we
know this marker or these set of markers
lead to this corn cart or this kernel
being white or yellow right things that
we can observe that have meaning and
value for our customers the way we make
those observations we have two different
resolutions the levels of resolution in
red you see low-density resolution what
that is is a smaller number of genetic
markers that we capture spread across
the genome and yellow you see high
density observations that's a lot more
markers it's also a lot more expensive
to collect right so these are things
where we're actually sending seeds to
the lab and we're running experiments to
get a window into the genome of these
corn seeds now if we want to capture low
density observations it's cheaper it's
easier it can be done more quickly but
still cost a lot of money still cost
money right and it's it's not just the
the money of running that experiment
it's all the shipping costs and all that
that comes into play to move seed to to
actually make those measurements what
we've done is we've leveraged
mathematics essentially and programming
and these technologies that you've seen
us see me talk about
to infer these genotypes which is at a
much cheaper cost we can basically take
the data that we've measured those two
different levels of resolution and we
can fill in the gaps we can up sample
the low-density resolution to a high
density resolution high resolution and
we can fill in those middle areas where
maybe we didn't collect any data at all
but we know genetically the seed came
from this seed came from this seed and
genetics tells us certain gives us
certain rules that we can put into play
and make estimations about what the
genome of that that particular scene in
the middle that of which we made no
direct observations actually looks like
we get a probabilistic value that allows
again our consumers to make the choice
of how confident do they need they want
to be about that picture of the genome
right again allowing the consumer to
make more decisions to give you a sense
of how much data we've generated with
this information pipeline what you see
again in yellow is the high-density
observations so we collected a lot of
information a lot of markers on a
smaller number of seats with the low
density observations we've collected a
lot fewer marker we've observed a lot
fewer markers but we've done it on a
wider larger number of seeds the blue is
the area that we filled in I talked to a
colleague this morning just to make sure
that my number was right on that number
or on that blue area we're talking about
197 billion genotypes that we were able
to generate and infer from those those
datasets this is something that was
previously unachievable and we've done
it at a much lower cost and we've done
it this way so let's let's walk through
this diagram real quick this is this is
our architecture for this destino type
inference pipeline let's talk about some
of those cut those principles that we've
we'd have we laid out earlier so if you
go left to right starting from the
bottom we've got a lab workflow a lab
system that's pushing data in
to our observed genotypes resource
that's backed by cloud spanner all of
that data is in cloud spanner from there
you get a cloud event you get that
asynchronous notification that new data
is arrived there's a component called
the orchestrator that's listening for
those events and then scheduling these
inference jobs and it's doing that on
kubernetes my way of gke has pub/sub
messages that get distributed across
multiple regions multiple kubernetes
clusters in multiple regions who then
those those pods their sole purpose in
life is to do that calculation for us to
do that calculation to infer these
genotypes they'll reach back in to our
our resource api's to grab those
observed genotypes when they complete
their purpose they'll write that new
data set out as inferred genotype into
our inferred genotype resource one
interesting thing about that one of the
spanner talks that we were in earlier
this morning they talked about using
spanner for GCSE metadata similar
approach here we actually use we store
the metadata for these data sets in
spanners so that we can more rapidly
search over it but the bulk of the data
the payload for that is stored in GCS
because it is large we're talking 85,000
genotypes for a single seed right and
then we're talking millions of seeds
that were we're inferring these
genotypes for so that that dataset grows
rapidly a few interesting
characteristics to facilitate this
workflow the workers actually run on
preemptable VMS so that's actually been
a huge mechanism for us to control costs
in this process preemptable vm's you get
at a fraction of the cost of a normal VM
but you get that resource those compute
resources for a limited amount of time
to engineer for resilience to preemption
we've done a couple of things one is
checkpointing so we checkpoint
intermediate State out to GCS as these
these workers run so that if they do get
preempted they can pick back up from
where they left off these jobs can be
long running on the order of minutes at
times just depending on how much day
there is for a particular particular
seed and with that in mind with those
that long-running characteristic in mind
we've implemented a job lock using cloud
memory store so pub/sub likes to try to
redeliver these messages sometimes
before we're ready for to be done with
them right so we've implemented we've
used memory store as a simple job lock
where we write some metadata to to
memory store as the job starts and then
if we get redeliver to message from
pub/sub we can check and ensure that we
we don't duplicate effort the last thing
I want to call out here is that again
this all comes back to these resource
api's we're reading from these resource
api's and writing output to these
resource api's we're dogfooding all of
these resource api's that were exposing
to our consumers we see the same surface
they do so that forces us to to make
sure that surface is coherent and usable
to give you a sense of how much data
we've generated again 197 billion
genotypes to backfill this the process
itself is meant to be always on right as
new data arrives we make new inferences
we had to backfill this in some way and
we did that again by dogfooding the
process at a single moment in time
actually during cloud next last year we
had a kubernetes cluster that was using
42,500 virtual CPUs all on preemptable
nodes at one time
270 terabytes of memory and when we talk
about cost we were doing this at 1 cent
per CPU hour which means that as we
scale this process up our costs don't go
out of control right this doesn't become
prohibitive
that's all I've got I that's my twitter
handle I'm always happy to we're always
happy to talk about what we do and how
we do it
[Music]